a level that you never put again always
push it over to the brand I never expect
your respect but British rate 50 to
beast I said so I saw Annabelle creation
last night and whilst to have some
problems with the movie mainly that old
cliche where someone's just about to
discover something really important and
then someone sneaks up behind them
hey why you don't wave it up though
those scares are always terrible and
really lazy and the movie was kinda
filled with a lot of them but it was an
okay film there are several aspects of
Annabelle creation based in real life
and well some of them mainly the entire
plot and backstory the film including
the dogs look history possession all of
its characteristics are nothing like the
movie version mainly that maybe that
maybe that it's interesting to see how
this small ghost story has boomed into a
massive worldwide phenomenon so I've
made a list of my top six Annabelle
facts that I think you're gonna enjoy
there are spoilers in here so don't
watch this if you want to see the movie
fresh she's not my kind of doll but I
have had a scary night with one or two
fact one in 1917 the woman purchased a
Raggedy Ann doll in a secondhand store
as a Christmas present for her daughter
Donna a nursing student in Hartford
everything seemed quite innocent until
Donna brought NFL to the kitchen for
breakfast where the dolls straightened
out her arms and put them on the table
allegedly from there things only became
weirder soon Donna and a roommate angie
often came home to find Annabelle on the
couch when she'd been left locked in
Donna's room at the height of her powers
Annabelle also proved to be a prolific
writer composing cryptic notes and
parchment paper again allegedly Leia
might not have happened after a month of
Annabelle's eerie antics Donna decided
to contact a medium the psychic told
Anna and Angie that a seven-year-old
girl named Annabelle had been tragically
slightly on the apartment property the
child had taken residence inside Donna's
doll Annabelle felt comfortable with
Donna Ranchi the young nurse is already
compassionate soul Society that there
was no harm and welcoming Annabelle into
their home
back-to-back two centers around the
Warrens which are the paranormal
investigators that appear in the
conjuring films after the attack on Lu
Donna asked her priest for help and that
ed and Lorraine Warren the Warren soon
came to the disturbing conclusion that
Donna's doll was not possessed by the
ghost of a young girl but a cunning
demon that had its sights on Donna's
soul the Warrens called in a priest to
perform an exorcism on Annabelle
afterwards Donna asked the Warrens to
take the doll with them anticipating
unholy activities the warrants avoided
the interstate and took the backroads
home after repeated trouble with the
engine brakes and steering head stopped
the car opening the trunk he doused
Annabelle with holy water
Annabelle behaved yourself at least for
a while fact 3 when Ed Warren recounted
Annabelle's story to a priest
the latter reportedly dismissed
Annabelle with you're just a rag doll
Annabelle you can't hurt anything
i Cory do the accidentally fed Lorraine
sense trouble for the priests and warned
him to drive carefully you later call to
tell the Rainey been in a near-fatal car
wreck on the way home when its brakes
failed one visitor to the occult Museum
broke the rules by oatman's Annabelle's
box and touching the doll
apparently challenging her to do you
were later that day the man allegedly
died in a motorcycle accident
his girlfriend survived but had to spend
nearly a year in the hospital recovering
from her injuries fact 4 director David
F Sandberg originally started out as a
YouTube video maker maybe it like myself
it's the career for people who can't get
a proper career he made a short
two-minute video in which a woman flicks
the lights in her home back and forth
between off and on seeing a mysterious
shadow when the lights are off after
going viral the director was given a
full feature-length movie on the video
and this layer became lights out
released in 2016 then later this YouTube
to Hollywood journey
Sam Berger New Line Cinema's a hole in
the competition and with YouTube
directors can submit a short two-minute
video that could potential
be made into a film however if you read
the small print on the contract you'll
soon discover that in doing so you no
longer own the rights to your film and
you only ever be given $100 no matter
how much they make from it Oh Thank You
Hollywood thank you so much not only can
you not come up with any original ideas
and you've had to resort to making
sequels and reboots all the [ __ ] time
you're now gonna steal ideas from
creative people and give them no money
for it thank you so much Hollywood fact
five recently we've seen a string of
masks on female characters and films
seven-letter dr. poison and Wonder Woman
Annabelle's mother wears a plastic mask
that covers her face before plastic
surgery was fully developed these masks
were used heavily by survivors of the
First World War and people with major
facial disfigurement fact 6 in the film
we get a minor glimmer of a nun in the
background of the photograph this
clearly shows that none from the
conjuring films played by Marilyn Manson
the film also neatly ties in with the
original Annabelle by ending where that
one begins
that's my six facts for the Annabelle
creation the crazy ghost stories comment
below let me know your thoughts and
please subscribe my channel if you want
to see more stupid videos of me being an
idiot thanks
[Music]